hello and welcome to the take with
Sophie rage live at nine here in the
heart of Westminster well wish you soon
X certainly isn't the first prime
minister to set a trap for himself in
that crucial first speech in Downing
Street but his promise to lead a
government of integrity at all levels
looks well a little tainted by Gavin
Williamson's third departure from
government this time over allegations of
bullying and as the opposition and
others question the new PM's judgment
there are more than a few on his own
side doing the same so plenty for us to
get stuck into as we bring you takes
from all sides over the next 60 minutes
he is a pathetic bully but he would
never get away with it if people like
the Prime Minister didn't hand him power
okay this time I wasn't holding back
over Gavin Williamson there was no
shortage of glum faces behind the Prime
Minister as he accepted that he I
obviously regret appointing someone who
has had to resign in these circumstances
well it was another tough pimp cues that
you saw there for uh Rishi sunak is any
honeymoon period now well and truly over
we'll have a look at what Sky News
viewers at home think with our regular
viewers uh panel I could see you are all
uh to hear today I will be talking to
you later on the show we'll also have
some top guests including the new chair
of the treasury select committee
conservative MP Harriet Baldwin and
we'll be talking to labor Shadow
attorney general Emily Thornbury much
more besides too on the take
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
now just before we start tonight I did
want to let you know that we do expect
to hear from Joe Biden fairly shortly
during the program the U.S president is
going to be speaking about the midterm
elections in America and the better than
expected performance by his party the
Democrats so we'll bring that to you
live just as soon as he does start back
here in the UK though I wish you soon
like looked particularly uncomfortable
in the house earlier facing questions
over judgment with Gavin Williamson who
of course played that big role in his
leadership campaign having to resign
again but news of Another Kind could
cause even greater disruption hundreds
of thousands of NHS nurses have voted
for strike action over pay and patient
safety all that as more rumors of
potential new tax Rises swell just eight
days until of course the chancellor
unveils his economic plans so let's
crack straight on we're going to start
with the best bits of the week so far
the Prime Minister has arrived in Egypt
for the climate Summit we can tell you
today that the United Kingdom is
delivering on our commitment of 11.6
billion pounds very important to deliver
on what we did at Glasgow I'm the spirit
of Glasgow that's what I'm doing here
I'm the spirit of Glasgow we are on a
highway to climate hell with our foot
still on the accelerator it's been
revealed that cabinet offers ministers
sir Kevin Williamson is under
investigation by the Parliamentary
Watchdog prime minister spokesperson
um today saying that the pm has full
confidence in Gavin Williamson I
actually served in the whips office
under Gavin Williamson and there was
always this great aura of you know do
you remember Cronus the spider the
tarantula and tonight we've heard from
the Civil Servant who alleges that
sagavan told him to Slit your throat
literally in the past few moments a
tweet has gone out with Gavin
Williamson's resignation unequivocally
the behavior complained of was
unacceptable and it is absolutely right
it is absolutely right that the right
honorable gentleman has resigned the
truth is simple he's a pathetic bully
but he would never get away with it if
people like the Prime Minister didn't
hand him power I obviously regret
appointing someone who has had to resign
in these circumstances
the story really has been running and
running this week hasn't it now the
chair of the treasury select committee
is always a really important job but
particularly right now you might have
noticed the economy is pretty important
at the moment and will of course be
getting the Chancellor's Autumn
statement in just eight days time but
today Harriet Baldwin was elected as the
second woman ever to hold the job she
gave her very first interview to this
program and I started by asking about
her vision for the new role
well of course being chair of the
treasury select committee at a time when
economics has really been at the
Forefront of the national story uh
couldn't be more of a privilege and I
think what the committee will try to do
is to be very uh much uh scrutinizing
both the treasury itself but also the
bank of England and the regulators and
challenging them without fear or favor
it's interesting you mentioned the bank
of England there do you think they need
challenging
well I certainly think they need
scrutinizing absolutely and it's one of
the key roles of the committee to do
that and we've got the bank of England
governor coming in uh quite soon uh one
of the things that I've been doing on
the committee I've been a member of the
committee for the last three years is
I've been really quite Cassandra like in
highlighting some of the inflationary
risks in the economy once we came out of
the pandemic and explain Cassandra to
yeah I know it's uh yeah no Cassandra
was the one who made lots of warnings
and no one listened to her and I've been
asking questions to the governor about
inflationary pressures in the economy
for a long time and it's disappointing
to see inflation has really got out of
its bottle in this country and we do
need the bank of England to make sure
that it gets back inside its bottle I
mean you say that you predicted that
um do you think the bank of England
should have been a bit quicker on that
as well then personally I would have
liked to see them move sooner in terms
of raising rates from what have been
incredibly abnormally low levels and
they were not just keeping rates very
low they were also buying lots of
government bonds and now of course
they've completely shifted course
they're in an environment where they're
raising rates but they've also started
to sell government bonds and so that
gives extra constraints in terms of what
the treasury can do and I think a
completely different environment for all
of us as consumers and people who pay
mortgages
you've got your work cut out for you
you're gonna have to get out the blocks
quite quickly because of course we've
got the Autumn statements later this
month at a time of rising debt Rising
inflation the chancellor has got to get
it right what do you think Jeremy Hunt
needs to do in that Autumn statement
well it's going to be such a challenge
isn't it because we've had quite a few
chancellors this year and one of them
who's now prime minister tried to to
raise taxes to pay for the two big items
in the budget they are catching up with
the NHS backlog and also all the help
that households are getting with their
heating bills this winter and those are
really important things to be doing and
it's a question of how do we pay for
them and then of course we had the
quasi-quarteng approach which was just
to borrow lots and we could see that
there were limits to that so what Jeremy
Hunter's chancellor has got to do is
he's got to tread a very fine line
between those two different approaches
so I think what we're hearing is that
there'll be a combination of what I call
economizing and also making sure that
the tax revenues are there to pay for
some of these very big ticket items it's
interesting you talked there about Rishi
sunak when he was Chancellor raising
taxes to pay for some of the spending do
you think he put up taxes too much then
or from a political point of view you'd
have to say that it did cost him votes
when the time came for the leadership
election and so I think he'll be very
aware of that against the backdrop and
we're all very much hoping that the
party has put those contests behind it
and that we are all now United but at
the same time I think it will mean that
he feels more cautious about the
potential for tax hikes to cause him
political difficulties
um economizing or spending cuts um also
of course proves a difficult politically
as well nurses are striking they say
that they want to pay rise five percent
above inflation so that would be 17 are
you sympathetic to public sector workers
who are on strike I think the really
important thing uh now is to make sure
that first of all those who are most
vulnerable get help with the cost of
living and you know this month alone 325
pounds is going out to those who are on
Universal Credit so there's a lot of
help also for pensioners but at the same
time we can't allow inflation to become
embedded in people's wage expectations
because then that just becomes an even
worse vicious cycle and what you're
seeing I think with the recommendation
uh from the Armslist body is something
like a four four and four and a half to
five percent they've recommended for
nurses I think off the top of my head
and and I believe that nurses are asking
for something like 17 now 17 feels like
really
um unaffordable and also the sort of
thing that would cause widespread
inflationary pressure across the economy
which hurts the poorest the most so I do
think I would urge all of the unions to
look at the full spectrum of support
that people getting for their household
budgets and not just focus on that Top
Line wage demand I guess the reason
people want their wages to keep up with
inflation is because they want to be
able to afford things right
after all the deductions um and with the
help that the government's giving so you
know everyone in the country is getting
400 pounds for example in terms of cut
from their electricity bill this winter
lots of pensioners are getting an extra
300 pounds with their winter fuel
payments and then of course taxes
themselves and National Insurance are
going to be lower than they were before
about 330 pounds so I think people have
got to look at everything in the round
because it's actually your net pay isn't
it after all that support that's really
helps you with your household budget and
it's not just the Top Line wage growth
and we don't want to see inflation get
embedded in the UK economy because that
really hurts the poorest the most
forgiven that do you think they're wrong
to be on strike
I would really be disappointed
um at strike action by nurses we've got
such a problem with the NHS backlog and
I know from my own constituency post bag
that we've got to really work flat out
to make sure that people have those
operations that they need and that
includes some of the less urgent things
which I believe are most affected by
this strike so I do think we've got an
arms length body that sets pay and
they've recommended a substantial
increase there's a lot of other help
with cost of living and I would prefer
to see our nurses not go on strike now
I do want to ask you about Gavin
Williamson who of course resigned for
his job at in government and there's
been a lot of criticism about the way
that he has operated now you work with
him I believe in the ministry of Defense
I did yes when I was a defense minister
he um he was promoted to be defense
secretary yes and then obviously stacked
by Theresa May for leaking information
if you had any run-ins with him would
you think that his behavior I guess
there's been red flags over his behavior
that you've been aware of previously I
would say he's always been incredibly
polite uh to me personally I did have to
call him up on his first weekend as
defense secretary to ask him to move the
tarantula out of the ministry of Defense
building and he obliged so you know I've
always had a very constructive
relationship with him and uh you know
he's he was very kind and got me
promoted as well so he brought the
tarantula into the administrative events
it was briefly there yes okay
um was a given and the complaint that
was against him was really seen like
wrong to appoint him to his government
I think with the benefit of hindsight
but as I understand it the Prime
Minister wasn't aware of all of these um
specific allegations at the time that he
made that appointment and I think today
in the Commons he was very clear about
that okay thank you very much thank you
Sophie thank you
so there you go Cronus Gavin
Williamson's tarantula not just with him
on his desk when he was Chief whip but
also when he was in the ministry of
defense and it sounds like it was
Harriet Baldwin and when she was a
junior Minister there he managed to
finally kick out Cronus we obviously uh
spoke about those nurses pay strikes as
well and the concern about pay packets
and obviously wages keeping up with
inflation following that interview we
spoke to Labor's Shadow returning
General Emily uh Thornbury let's have a
little listen to what she had to say
the rural College of Nursing has voted
on strike for the first time in its
history do you have sympathy with
striking workers
oh yeah I mean
to them doesn't seem to be talking to
them the last time that any Secretary of
State spoke to the nurses was three or
was it four secretaries of States ago it
was such a Javed they're not being
listened to and frankly what the
government should be doing is sitting
down at a table with them and talking it
through any strike is a failure it's a
failure of negotiation nobody wants to
be on strike the patient certainly don't
want the nurses on strike the nurses
don't want to be on strike the
government ought to be sorting this out
during the whole time when labor was in
power we never had a strike in the NHS
at all you know these nurses haven't
been on strike if since their existence
something has gone wrong and frankly I
think that what's gone wrong is we don't
have a government that is prepared to be
flexible to think things through and to
work with those who we all got outside
our doors every Thursday night and and
applauded at the same time though you
say something's gone wrong yeah some
would say they think that has gone wrong
is inflation right it's it's Sky High
well it's more Royal College of nurses
are saying they want to pay rise that's
five percent above inflation that's 17
isn't that a bit too much it isn't just
inflation it's also that they are
exhausted you talk to anybody working in
the NHS it doesn't take very long to
really appreciate just how exhausted
they are how they have been taken for
granted how they have been worked into
the ground how there aren't enough of
them they can't take any time off sick
they dance they don't take any time out
we need to get the cavalryers coming we
have a plan for introducing many more
nurses into the system so 10 000 more a
year that we have a plan for we had to
we're going to double the number of
places for people training up to be
doctors and increasing the number of
Health visitors and just bringing some
more people in just to help out will in
itself make a huge difference would you
grant the 17 pay rise I think the truth
is is that we don't know what the state
of the economy is we couldn't sit down I
can't tell you now does it sound
reasonable to you what sounds reasonable
is that we pay our nurses properly and
we give them Fair pay and we recognize
how important they are but we also have
to do it within the confines of what the
what the you know what sort of State the
economy is in now you know so therefore
we would need to be able to see the
books we would need to know what the
flexibility was and we would then know
what we could negotiate around but we
have a government that isn't even
prepared to negotiate we don't know for
example what is going to be in the obr
the the office of budget
responsibilities report on how much mess
the economy is in since these Tories
have been messing around with it we
don't know how bad things are at the
moment we
have a pretty good idea don't we though
about the economic picture right we know
that there is a black hole the obr have
told us that the ifs had done their
projections as well we know the
difficulties the economy is facing in
that would labor Grant a 17 payroll as I
say I'm not in a position you know to do
this and I can't write a Manifesto
sitting here with you much as I'd like
to you know and unfortunately we think
there's probably going to be two years
and with apologies too and we thought we
were going to go straight to the United
States where President Joe Biden is
speaking about those midterm election
results
thank you for watching uh the take a bit
of a different episode of the program
for us tonight lots more coming up
though at Sky News at 10 where we'll
have more news of course on those
midterm elections as well as all the
latest here in the UK